- [Sarah] The funny thing
is this video started as
me just trying to learn
about an Instagram trend.
Now, we're going to
find out if people know
what the "Barbie Feet" trend is,
where people imitate Barbie's
feet and it has somehow
turned into something...
- Yeah, I look really good.
... wildly different.
All of this makes me feel
concerned and worried.
- [Man] Dude, it's okay. You're ugly.
- [Sarah] Is that Barbie?
(band music plays)
So, why did I decide to try
to become a life-size Barbie?
- The idea first came to
me when I was asking people
on the street questions
about "Barbie Feet."
- I've not heard of the Barbie trend.
- Oh, are they going like this?
- Pretending you have a high heel on.
- It's, like, go on your tip-toes.
- It makes their butts stick
out, their chest stick out.
- Can elongate your leg or
make it look more toned.
- If people feel that it's unrealistic,
then they don't need to wear heels.
- [Sarah] Her hair, her
waist, her proportions,
are they unattainable?
- For who, because-
Me.
- when you are born, that
is the body you're given.
- Like, oh, I want to look like Barbie.
It's, like, Barbie's plastic.
- Like, what we imagine to
be, like, a pretty girl,
tall, and slim, and, like, her
make-up is done all the time.
- Barbie has unrealistic proportions.
- [Sarah] I mean, she is pretty perfect.
- We all want to be like her.
- I can't imagine a real
person looking like that.
- [Sarah] People kept talking about her
unrealistic body proportions,
and I just got to thinking,
like, can I have her perfect proportions?
You're saying you don't
think that I can make myself
look more like Barbie?
- Oh, you can look just
like Barbie if you want,
but is that what you
want? Is that what anybody
really needs to be happy?
That is the question.
If life is about being happy,
do you need to look more like
Barbie to be happy? And the
answer is absolutely not.
- [Sarah] Yes, I want to
look like Barbie. I mean,
I didn't really think
that before today, but
her body proportions,
I can figure this out.
I need to figure out what
Barbie's real-life proportions
would be, and compare them to my own.
A lot of people make the
mistake of measuring Barbie's
height from her head to her
tippy toes, which is incorrect.
You have to measure at the heel.
You don't go to the
doctor's wearing high heels
and measure yourself.
To find out Barbie's sizes in real life,
you need to times all of
her measurements by six.
Like her height actually
ends up being my height,
which is perfect, and is
like, okay, here we go.
But then she has some
freaky proportions from,
since her waist, it's about,
like, around a 20-inch waist,
20, 21-inch waist which I can't
make my waist that size...
Ever.
So, I have to one-to-one from somewhere,
and then I have to make
everything else bigger.
That's the only way I can do it.
This has become like a math
problem that I need to solve.
I got the numbers, now I just
got to make them reality.
- [Robotic Voice] Barbie.
- [Sarah] Her feet are miniscule.
Okay, feet, feet, feet, feet.
Okay, like, a little
over three centimeters.
When we do the math on this,
multiply by six, then
we'll times the 1.3 to...
Barbie needs to be about
7.8 times larger than
actual Barbie to make any sense.
That way, I can have a waist.
In order for my thigh
circumference to make any sense,
I need to make myself taller,
I need to make my hair longer,
I need to make my hips bigger,
but my boobs can pretty much
stay the same. Turns out, she
is pretty, like, of average,
even below average sized breasts, and...
so do I.
So, it's kind of nice.
I'm going to bring in my friend Joanna,
she is a doll expert.
Hopefully, she'll be able to
help me figure out how
I can become Barbie.
- I guess I have some
experience with dolls,
I've purchased a lot of
haunted dolls off of eBay
that's my main experience with dolls.
- So, like a doll expert with a speciality
in the haunted type.
- Sure.
- I'm trying to make my body like Barbie's
'cause I feel like I was
challenged to do it by
some people out on the streets.
I just want to prove that I can.
- I would say that my
relationship to Mary, the
haunted doll, is a lot
different from your relationship
to Barbie, because I have
never tried to look like
a haunted doll.
- Okay.
- You have a lot of numbers written down.
- Yeah, I do. Okay.
- There's a lot of math involved.
- All right, so -
- All of this makes me
feel concerned and worried.
- Why?
As you can see-
- Oh my God.
This is like a job for Engineer Barbie.
- Mhmm. I think I need to gain like around
19 inches in height,
I think.
- Wow.
- So my haunted doll, for her height,
she has like a doll stand.
I feel like stilts, maybe,
are similar to, like,
the doll stand.
- [Camerawoman] Yeah, Sarah, how are you
going to hold a mic?
- I don't know.
I need to make my butt bigger.
I need to, I guess, kind
of, pinch in my waist.
Her head is much bigger.
So, like, I basically need
my head to go from this to this.
- Like, maybe, like a helmet,
or something like that?
- Okay. Her hair is long, but that's easy.
It's like a wig. You just
get a really long-ass wig.
The one other big issue I'm
having, her pupillary distance,
I did the math, is double
my pupillary distance.
- Wait, so, like, her eyes
are farther apart than yours?
- Mhmm, mhmm.
Okay.
I think I'm going to need to
draw on some eyes, though.
Yeah, for sure.
For sure. Okay, yeah.
I love doing make-up. I love
doing special effects make-up.
- Do you get a lot of people coming to you
asking you to look like Barbie?
- Never.
Never?
- I've probably done something
in the field of a doll.
- I need you to change my
eye to be, like, over here.
You think you can do that?
- Yeah.
- Okay, thank God.
- I could weave brows, then cover them.
- [Sarah] We can just start.
Maybe I'm going to become
the most attractive woman in the world
after this make-up is done.
Are my eyebrows gone?
- [Frances] Almost.
(light orchestral music)
- [Frances] I think you look beautiful.
- [Sarah] Yeah, I look really good.
- [Frances] You do look beautiful.
(light orchestral music)
Okay so we're just going
to the outline of the eye.
(light orchestral music)
All right, so we're going
to glue these to the top
of your eye. Really realistic.
(light orchestral music)
Wow, so beautiful. All right,
you are done. Check it out.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God. I really do look
very shiny and plastic.
- Is that Barbie?
- Shut up. Do you think everybody
will understand what I am
when they see me?
- Yes.
- Okay, so I've got my
giant eyes and I've got
my bigger hips. Oooh, you can hear it.
My waist tied as tight as possible.
So I'm getting more Barbie shaped.
So, you can see what I've
done here is I taped a helmet
Okay.
Gosh.
Maybe the eyes are too big.
Okay, here we go.
Did I do it? Do you think I did it?
I mean, I still need to grow
taller, but I feel pretty good.
(light orchestral music)
- Do you know who I am?
Can you tell who I am?
Could you tell who I am?
- No.
- Tippy Hedren.
- You look like a doll.
- Do you have an guesses now?
- Are you Barbie?
- Yes, I am, thank you.
Do you think from afar
you would think that
Barbie became a real-life person?
- If I saw you?
- Yeah.
- Well, I might get fooled,
yeah. I mean, I'm easily fooled.
- Yeah, it's kind of unbelievable.
I'm in shock right now, I guess.
- Yeah, I get it.
- You're so tall, you know?
- Do you think Barbie is extra?
- Like, she definitely does the most.
- Barbie is like, kind of, known as having
these unattainable proportions.
But I'm here out to prove
that it is realistic,
and it is attainable,` and it can be done.
- You look great.
- Thank you.
- Look at my eyes.
- They're closed.
- No they're not.
- No, they made them bigger.
- Wow, those are some serious eyeballs.
- Your stance is also awesome.
Super stable.
- Seems like it'd be a
lot of work to get this
whole look going.
- Yeah, it was a lot of work.
- I think you put a lot of
effort into becoming Barbie.
- Thank you.
- I measured Barbie. I found
out if I times all of her
measurements by 7.8, I
could accurately be Barbie.
That meant her head was
big, and her eyes were big,
- Yeah.
- And she's really tall.
But I figured out a way to do it.
I got them exactly right.
- So?
- What? What do you mean so?
- It looks like you're
struggling on the stilts.
- Yeah, I wouldn't want those.
- It's not great...
- What? I spent days on this.
- It does make you look a little freakish.
- (cries) Oh my God!
Why are they saying that?
In that moment, I thought of Barbie.
I copied her proportions, her
height, her hair, her eyes,
but I forgotten to copy
her most important feature,
her smile.
Barbie doesn't cry. Barbie doesn't cry.
Barbie always smiles.
- You okay?
- I'm okay. Barbie doesn't cry.
- Barbie is not all
she's cracked up to be.
- And I'm smiling through the pain,
but I'm really upset right now.
But, Barbie only smiles,
so I can only smile.
- [Woman] Right.
- [Sarah] Do you think it was worth it?
- I think anything that
brings Barbie to the forefront
is probably a good idea.
- You're probing a nice
point that, you know-
- What point?
- Barbie's pretty ridiculous.
- People need to reevaluate
why that icon was
important in the first place.
- Barbie smiles no matter what.
Honestly, I didn't even measure that.
It's the things you don't
measure, that mean the most.
"Barbie feet" is an
Instagram trend whereas
Barbie is timeless. You
can't become Barbie.
She's crazy proportions.
I proved them wrong,
and I proved me beautiful.
- Hey, "Unsolved" is on
a new channel, and now your part.
- Subscribe here!
Subscribe here!
- That was my part.